congressman Ron de santis is a
Republican representing the state of
Florida and joins this any connection
thanks coming up
good evening so the meeting that Susan
Rice describes in her email between the
president vice president's Elliot's
Comey is really revealing so Trump was
accused of considering Obama foreign
with the birther stuff but Obama
actually turned out didn't consider
Trump foreign a foreign agent can a
sitting president deny government
documents intelligence to an incoming
president I don't see how you can do
that I mean just think about what Yates
was on to at the time with Michael Flynn
ret met with kiss Lee act the Russian
ambassador that was one of the reasons
why she sent the FBI agents to Flynn
once he got in so they were creating
some type of a boogeyman really out of
Flynn acting like any incoming national
security adviser would a president's
authority and legitimacy comes from
voters winning an election that's what
makes you the president so how can one
president say I don't think the next guy
should have this I don't think he's
worthy of this information and it
doesn't yeah I don't know I mean I don't
think I think it's improper to do that
and it's interesting this January 5th
meeting in the Oval with Comey what did
Comey do that very next day that was
when he briefed Trump on the dossier
he went to Trump Tower he showed him the
dossier that eventually got leaked to
CNN and then that allowed the dossier to
get put out into the bloodstream also
during this whole transition time you
have an unprecedented campaign of
leaking classified information designed
to put a cloud over Trump's incoming
presidency so I think Susan Rice has a
lot of questions that she's gonna have
to answer why would you all of a sudden
write as you're leaving the White House
do that email saying Obama said do it by
the book it's just a really odd thing to
do she was trying to create a record and
the question is why did she feel the
need to do that well what's the answer I
think we have to find out the answer I
mean I think that it was clear that by
the time Trump got inaugurated I mean
you had the permanent bureaucracy in the
Obama holdovers I mean they were putting
feeding information to the press on a
daily basis the first two or three
months of his administration was
constant bombshell reports quote-unquote
all based on anonymous sources all based
on former or current US officials and
that really started from the day he
elected all the way until the
appointment of Robert Muller is special
counsel so the dossier itself which is
the center of all this dusty that
BuzzFeed published Republic consumption
claims that Trump was being cultivated
by Russian intelligence for five years
prior to becoming president is there any
evidence that's true no evidence that
that's true and you think about even
what they use for Carter page I mean the
idea that the Russian oil company energy
company was going to give him a 10%
stake or 20% stake in a company that is
so big that would have been 10 billion
dollars that they were going to give the
Carter page and the FBI used that to get
surveillance so the only thing that has
definitely been corroborated is that
Carter page did travel to Russia during
the campaign he did that he gave a
public speech none of the other key
facts have been corroborated at all I'm
not surprisingly you know I am i
overstating it when i say as just a
normal person reading the dossier it
seems prima facie absurd look you'd have
to be a [ __ ] to take that at face value
is that was that your reaction to it
yeah that's my reaction I think it's
spectacular and I think it's something
that Comey was actually right about
salacious but unverified and yet they
used it as the basis for spine that's
upsetting a judgment thank you thank you